[Music]
where are we here cece what's up cece
hi merry christmas john you know what
merry christmas to you too
thank you i cannot believe kelly deemed
me worthy
i am here
hey
she has not deemed me worthy so
congratulations this is a big this is a
big thing this is jack for sure way to
go all right so what's up
well
two years ago i was diagnosed with
bipolar with mixed episodes and since
then i'm really trying to find a way to
protect my marriage and to protect my
daughter from the aspects of the illness
okay
so what's the best way to do that
got it let's fix it you ready
yeah
so let's i want to take the diagnostic
and just put it away for a while okay
okay tell me about your marriage and
your kids how long you've been married
all that stuff okay so we got married in
2014
and right away we started trying to have
kids
and it didn't happen
so for five years we were going through
fertility treatment
and that was really really rough his dad
died his sister died um so like we were
dealing with trauma after trauma
and then um we were super blessed to
have a daughter in 2019
and so she's two years old right now and
she's doing great
how long have you
wrestled with
some of the symptomologies
oh um i can remember the depression
reaching back into like high school for
sure
and my parents were definitely begging
me to like get help or like medication
and i was like no no it's just a season
i don't need this well
one season always ended up going into
another season into another season it
just got kind of deeper and deeper
so
i didn't really notice manic symptoms
until
after i had the baby
and i went
for help
for
postpartum and they recommended me to a
psychiatrist and a psychiatrist said
these hallucinations you're having these
uh interesting thoughts you're having
they're really not postpartum it's
bipolar so that's how i ended up there
so will you do me a favor
nope you know what it's not even doing
me a favor
you and i are best friends for sure
but
um
this favor is for you
okay for your kids and your
child and future kids to come if y'all
so
choose
for your
husband
um i want you to go
talk to somebo some people in your
community
okay and find a good do you have a good
relationship with your ob gyn now
um
yeah pretty good yeah
is this is he or she
he yep did he is he the one who referred
you out to psychiatrist or did you meet
with him
um i met with his
uh social worker at his office okay and
they referred me out okay i want you to
get a second opinion on that okay
okay
um
i'll just leave it at that
um okay i'll i'll leave it at that um
talk to me about mixed emotions that's a
very that's a very niche
um bipolar diagnostic
what does that mean to you
um so at the time i'm trying to dig back
because it's been two years now um
so at the time it felt like
i could crawl out of my skin
um like i was so depressed and at the
same time like i was just shaking inside
my body so like so for the me that mixed
really
it
it kind of surprised me because i i
don't
i don't quite understand it you know
what i mean like
hmm um
here's here's the way i've heard it
described is
um so for instance if you meet somebody
with bipolar and they're having a manic
episode
it's
in all honesty it's one of my favorite
people on earth to be around
there it's it's mayhem and it's chaos
and it is laughter and it is a thousand
miles an hour and the folks i've i've
that i'm in close relationship
who have bipolar manic phases they're
one
i laugh so hard they're they're a it's
just it's a it's a it's a roller coaster
my understanding of
and this so rare that's what i'm asking
you is a mixed emotion would be um
somebody who is
oh let me back up somebody
with bipolar without mixed emotions they
are running high and it's this sense of
optimism this sense of i can take on the
world it is the sense of
i can do everything better than you and
in in my case they're right like they
can get stuff done in three days that it
would take me two weeks to do right
um the mixed emotions is their body is
running like that but their mind is
still super sad
their mind is still super depressed they
still they have no optimism they've got
no
um energy about accomplishment and what
we're going to do and we're going to
turn this core and then you and i are
going to get married and we're going to
do this and this and this and this it's
not that their body's running that fast
but their heart and spirit is still
under the cover saying i just want this
to stop
yeah i don't know if it's ever been like
that before like it was mostly just like
um
like everything is so so so so bad
and i can't stop the world around me to
take a breath hmm
so i'm i'm gonna give you
i'm gonna give you my opinion and that's
okay it's gonna be worth what you're
paying for it okay
okay
um i do not like
at all
i do not like
somebody i don't like postpartum
diagnostics
and i don't mean postpartum not
postpartum depression as as in another
diagnostic but
somebody who is struggled for years of
infertility someone's gone through lots
of trauma somebody who then has a baby
and how was your how was your pregnancy
was it carefree and exciting
yeah it was it was just fine it was like
the depression like abated for a while
okay
and then your body goes through the what
just happened after the baby's born and
everybody experiences that different
that re-regulation the hormones the
what's life gonna be like your
relationship with your husband's
different he's got his trauma he's
dealing with and now he's got a little
kid and how's this gonna look and any
old stuff from your past is now coming
up and then his
and then just
tag somebody in the middle of that
with a diagnosis of a mental health
disorder
feels not right to me well and the funny
thing is is that um
i i found it out by accident she the
psychiatrist never told me she just
threw some pills at me and i went online
to take care of a bill on my
uh app for the hospital
and i looked at i just happened to look
at my notes and the diagnostic was on
there and i had to ask her like is this
really what's going on and she's like
well yes
because
your dad is bipolar oh my gosh dude go
get another
so you're going to get me all fired up
and i'm going on vacation tomorrow so
listen i'm so sorry no don't be sorry
you don't apologize for me nothing man
i'm on same team i want you to go get a
second opinion and i want you to walk
them through what happened okay okay so
how how far removed are you from your
initial diagnosis
um two years okay so bring me throw the
diagnosis put it in a drawer and let's
close that drawer
okay right now something is worrying you
about the way you are parenting the way
you are loving your husband the way
you're taking care of your family and
friends the way you're taking care of
yourself what about your environment now
what about you right now is making you
nervous to ask how do i protect my kid
and my marriage from me
um so
i feel like i'm not as emotionally
available as i should be
who told you you should be what
well
so like um my my husband was like i can
never make you happy and then
i i just kind of translated that into
like
i'm
i'm not showing him enough that i'm
happy and if i'm not
showing my emotions am i
hurting my family by like not
not showing them that that i'm okay with
with
our dynamics if that makes sense
so are you feeling joy at home and it's
just not demonstrative or are you
are you running pretty low are you
remembering back to high school when you
when you just ran low
um
it
i i feel like i'm fine inside and that
the world is like never like my
the people around me aren't seeing it
okay because they'll be like are you
having a bad day today what's wrong
today and i'm like i'm i'm fine i'm just
a resting witch face i don't know
whatever no you're not
so here's
i'm afraid that my daughter
will
not think that i love her because i'm
not showing her that i'm happy
um
okay and i think it's part of like what
i experienced like my dad emotionally
withdrew when he had his breakdown
and so i'm afraid that i'm doing that
now so let's not be afraid let's let's
speak in in data points
okay are you withdrawing from your
daughter
um
they're
yeah
at some level because there'll be days
where i just
i can't i can't function that well and
i feel guilty about that yeah
are you withdrawn from your husband
i'm trying very hard not to okay
i'm like if i if i realize that i'm
doing it then i i
go and like give him a hug or touch his
face or there you go yeah you know like
scratches back or something like to
physically connect us
um
but so cece can i ask you something
let me
children of somebody with true bipolar
disorder
they often will spend their life trying
to make sure everybody else is okay
because they had to
right
[Music]
and
they become the broker of joy in the
house they become the peacemaker in the
house they become the
agent of safety in the house
and it's both exhausting and not their
job it is in that time but then that
same
over time it becomes not your job in
your workplace or in your marriage or
wherever
so let me ask you this
what do you need right now
you're doing a lot of thinking for other
people
yeah for sure what do you need
i need to just like relax like
just let it go you know
don't hold it back anymore that was just
my frozen reference sorry
what do you want to let go
i want to let go like uh
like the responsibility i feel over
other people
but you have responsibility of your
daughter
well yeah
yeah
here's here's
all right here's my full recommendation
you ready
ready
the things you're describing to me
on a three-minute phone call right or
10-minute phone call
sound a lot like an exhausted parent of
a two-year-old
sound like somebody who's married to
some
to somebody that she loves and y'all
have been through hell and back the last
five or six years and you've probably
kept running and kept running and kept
running and at some point that trauma
catches up with everybody
it sounds like a
new mom
who grew up in a disconnected home
and growing up in the home of somebody
with bipolar is chaotic and it's scary
and sometimes it's scary because that
person disappears and sometimes it's
scary because that person's sitting
right there and they're not even present
and was your mom married to him
yes yeah they stayed married through the
whole thing but it was
it was rocky
that's right so i want you to think in
terms of your body your body remembers
this story and it doesn't end well
and so what your body's trying to do is
protect you
from a story that it knows and what you
have to do is to teach your body
both through thinking and through how
you act
that you're safe now this is a new story
this is different
and some of that retraining your body
will come through partnership with a
psychiatrist if you have bipolar
disorder
some of that will come through marriage
counseling because your husband's going
to have his own trauma work to do too
he's had a lot of loss
and a he's been
in his head he's been propping up a
scared wife for five years or six years
or a heartbroken wife or an exhausted
wife or whatever right
and now you got a two-year-old and
you're looking at your relationship
saying what what do we do now
and it's all different
and when things get all different then
we start putting stories in each other's
heads
and his story is she doesn't like me
because if she liked me it would look
like this
and your story is
if i wasn't broken i would be acting
like that
and what i want you all to do is to go
see a good marriage counselor and say we
have a new baby we've been through a lot
of loss we've been through 2020 2021.
i've got to deal with my dad's stuff
you've got to deal with all the loss and
your dad's stuff
let's do this together and then you're
going to get some new tools and probably
neither of you have any sort of model
for what this will look like
fair
very fair yeah so here's what i want the
word i want you to keep in your head as
you move forward is curious not
judgmental
okay okay
listen to me closely you are not
broken
your body's trying to take care of you
okay
thank you
do you you promise you hear me
yes okay
a psychiatrist or a counselor or a
mental health practitioner should never
ever
secretly diagnose you with something
in order to throw pills at you or to get
some sort of insurance reimbursement if
somebody's going to tag you with a label
that will last forever
diagnostically
they should sit down and walk you
through what this means how y'all will
be in partnership together
as you learn new ways to live and to
love and to connect
and what role pharmaceuticals will play
and how short of a time it will that
will play they should they have should
have a heart of a teacher
they should not be
they should not have secrets
it's unethical it's nonsense
it's not a it's not a partnership you're
worth more than that that's what i'm
telling you okay cc
thank you
now you may go meet with psychiatrists
and they're like for sure bipolar for
sure
okay
right and what that will mean is you're
going to sit down with a marriage
counselor and your husband and y'all are
going to walk through
what does making sure i take my medicine
look like what does making sure i move
my body and i take a bunch of fish oil
every single day even when i don't want
to what's it look like to make sure i'm
having skin-to-skin contact with family
members even on the days i want to crawl
under my blankets and not come out
what's it look like the days you leave
me alone and let me have my day under
the blanket so i can come out strong the
next day what does exercise look like
when i can't move my body
right that's when you get in that's what
creating a life worthy of living
we're like of worthy of having joy and
laughter and fun and and dealing with
bipolar
that's what that life looks like it's
intentionality it's about thoughts and
behaviors it's not about the diagnostic
the diagnostic part of life is what it
is what it is
you haven't convinced me you have
bipolar is what i'm saying and we've
only talked for 10 minutes so i don't
know you that well your husband may be
like for sure bipolar
um
i don't like this i don't like the way
the whole thing was done
it just feels gross to me
that you take somebody in the middle of
a mess and tag them forever i don't like
it
and i didn't go to med school so put
your mean notes in the in the in the
youtube comments
fun ruiners
but i do want you to go get a second
opinion you're worth that i do want you
and your husband to be curious about one
another and go to a marriage counselor
and say all right we got a new baby
we've had a lot of trauma we're in this
together for the long haul and so we're
gonna have to find new ways to talk to
each other new ways to be sexually
intimate together new ways to
parent because we've never seen it done
right before or not right we've never
seen done healthy before
we got all this new stuff to learn and
i'm so glad i get to do it with you and
we're gonna figure this thing out
together so go see somebody make both of
those calls today make them both today
you're going to be on the road to
healing